people love blood when it's not their
own but tavern brawls are boring and
Wars never have good seating
thus defamed fighting pits of marine
opened shortly after the city's own
founding and I heard that originally the
combats were a blood sacrifice to the
gods of geese the empire that founded
marine some still believe they are but
the ghiscari empire died a long time ago
and their gods went with them yet the
pits remained open filling the city's
purse with gold from the ends of the
earth
I suppose the fighting pits are a blood
sacrifice after all only the gods
changed in the pits slaves fought each
other to the death for fame and glory
and gold for their masters a lot of gold
enough for the Masters to invest in
rigorous training slaves were taught to
fight like Dothraki screamers bedded
priests of norvos Ironborn Reavers
Westerosi knights co horik hunters and
least seen pirates whatever would excite
a crowd after all everyone wants to know
who is the best and of course who isn't
for the crowds don't come only to see
men fight well I've seen the Masters
released tigers lions and other exotic
beasts into the arena to chase less
constantly slaves barely trained if at
all our Hall once told me of an
amusement in one of the less prestigious
bits one boy was rolled in honey one in
blood and one in rotting fish and then a
bear was unleashed and the crowd wagered
on which boy the bear would eat first
I never heard who won then again it was
obvious the Masters did such stories
worried me of course not I could fight
and for a good fighter life was
luxurious thousands of people chanted
his name when he stepped into the pits
he would eat the choicest meats drink
the finest wines and sleep on exotic
first often not alone women would fling
themselves at him was sneaked into his
chambers to wait for him after a fight
foreign princess
priestesses and even the wives and
wayward daughters of masters may never
had a fear punishment for a great
fighter could be worth three hundred
thousand honors another wife was always
cheaper and when this renowned fighter
finally fell for all fighters will in
time his name would be inscribed into
the gates of fate among the other
valiant dead
I remember once trying to count the
names but the gates opened before I
finished and another fight began